you know I've been thinking about did
you see that Roku is I think deep
platformed Infowars yes instantly like
within a day but I wanted to ask you
before we get to that okay cuz I have to
say I feel I think I support that
because I don't want like in an age in
which people don't know okay like a 15
year old clicking through their Roku
doesn't necessarily know the difference
between CNN and Infowars and the New
York Times and MSNBC and whatever and of
course some of those other ones have
biases obviously but Infowars promotes
conspiracy theories and do I want a 15
year old kid stumbling into that and
thinking that that information is on par
on a level with actual facts
the problem with conspiracy theories is
that some of them are real this is the
real problem the problem is you don't
know which ones are real but some of
them are real the gulf of tonkin that
got us into the vietnam war you're aware
that okay but Sandy Hook okay Sandy Hook
for sure happened bunch of kids died and
these are horrible these are horrible
evil conspiracies
the problem is promoted by right Alex
Jen yes it's horrible without a doubt
and you know and I saw the Media Matters
clip that I'd never seen before
I saw it recently which clip the one
that shows every time he brought it up
oh he's not just one time oh I know it's
many many many times and was saying it
was an app has he ever apologized he's
backed off of the position now but I
think because of the lawsuit or I'm sure
it's a lot of things I'm sure it's the
pressure it's hurts
it has to be a realization that he knows
that it really did happen but there's a
giant group of people out there that
still believe it didn't happen and they
still confront these parents even in
court and they call them crisis I know I
know the times it's done amazing
reporting on this Elizabeth Williamson
mild it's sick it's sick
it's twisted we probably shouldn't I
mean we can go into conspiracy theories
I just don't know to go into it's not a
bad thing to go into cuz it's a thing
okay but it's it's you know I'm curious
what you think your own what do you
think of Roku taking in foot wars off oh
I think we have to decide
what what is Twitter what is Facebook
yeah what is YouTube the position that
most people have is these are private
companies they can make their own rules
this is just like CBS deciding that if
you use you know if you drunkenly yell
the n-word out at a black police officer
that they don't want you as a newscaster
anymore what you know yeah there's a
public account or a private company that
can make these distinctions if you take
a position an anti-semitic position
publicly they can they can decide look
we don't want you on the air anymore and
then there's other people that think
freedom of speech in this form is so
important and that the answer to bad
ideas is not stopping those ideas it's
good ideas it's good ideas confronting
those ideas and you see it all work
itself out that's that's the that's the
other side of the coin that's the other
side of the argument the argument that
we should treat whether it's Twitter or
YouTube or any of these social media
platforms as a public utility and then
you should be able to distribute
information
the real problem is with all this is
that it's very messy the the the there's
this is a nuanced issue there's a lot
going on because when you do decide to
deep platform someone for having an
awful position and spreading a false
conspiracy about that most people are
going to agree with you but the question
is does it stop there exactly and
doesn't move on to you or a person who
believes in white nationalism what does
that mean well I believe that black
pride is fine but I also believe white
pride is fine what about those people
where do we go with them right then it
gets slippery what about the outright
adjacent people yeah all right Jason I
totally get people that have given the
alt-right a platform you know what are
they are they a part of the problem now
should we deep platform them I mean this
is one of the things that there was a
paper that someone had put together an
article it was hilarious where it's like
everyone has this very bizarre
connection it's six degrees of Kevin
Bacon exactly and but but they're using
it in terms of like way the connections
is almost of its scientific data well
they would basically say a view or of
something
someone like well they did say you're me
they said of you your gateway to the
alt-right
yes yes so what I said is Barbara
Walters interviewed Castro does that
make her a communist right exactly
[ __ ] are you talking about exactly
pretty left like just ask me questions
like if you want to know I'm not gonna
hide my positions on things from you I'm
very open obviously I told people I used
to believe the moon landings faked I'll
tell you all the stupid [ __ ] I believed